oh my gosh y'all I'm so excited right
now we're backstage okay let's see this
is us I'm so excited I'm just so much
heart it's such a great show I'm so
super stoked my new neighbors oh hey
what's up Chris Christie what's going on
neighbor I'm a neighbor now so I brought
y'all a bundt cake alright so I know
that your show is so beautiful and it's
hard it's all about you know y'all this
is us right everybody left it but I
thought I'm your new neighbor so like
maybe you want to know like about me
like this is me like maybe I don't know
are you into it alright no no please
alright well since we're neighbors I'll
just let you know in case gifts come up
um I like quilting I like ear candling I
like wine
I do have normally short arms kind of
like t-rex really they're not like my
height and they're supposed to be I have
four children and I love denim i love
denim make some work yes yes that's just
a little bit about me yes I want to do a
little game with y'all yeah I know who
are you that's right dog or cat person
dog oh I love your coffee or tea coffee
yeah vanilla chocolate chocolate can you
sing your favorite musical notes and
your favorite key middle C
now
[Music]
okay go to Dan Smith I like a Carlton
yes my yam I just sort of like what's
your favorite spirit anymore
Oh Nick Offerman I love ya he's my
spirit animal that is great they're
swinging and helpful yeah my spirit
animal is Dixie Carter from designing
women' just if you wanted to know
perfect who's your favorite new kid on
the block tonight oh my god okay so
what's worse loud neighbor or like
overly friendly neighbor loud neighbor
okay good then you'll love me loud yeah
but you brought clothes get rid of that
handshake I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this